et ça va ou quoi aujourd'hui la sphère
1-10 du coup bas à j'avais oublié
pendant un instant grâce au fonds vert
je croyais que tout était comme abord l
on en parle de luile mais [ __ ] comment
il nous a soulevé en plus il est mignon
plus j'arrive même pas lui en vouloir
j'ai envie de le caresser ce qu'on
écoute et je me vois mal continuer à
faire des vidéos comme avant sans faire
une vidéo qui parle de tout ça quoi
c'est quand même incroyable ce qui se
passe est une crise sanitaire folle
c'est historique c'est la première fois
moi je vis à la d re fois que j'ai vu ça
c'était dans des films et d'ailleurs
dans les films les gens n'avaient pas du
tout la réaction qu'il fallait gens
rient ils foncer droit dans le mur quoi
heureusement la réalité bien différente
alors avant de parler de trucs positifs
et de rationaliser tout ça et qu'on
kiffe un peu je veux juste revenir sur
tout ce qui s'est passé parce que mec
j'ai été abasourdi ça m'a fatigué ou
alors j'ai le corps on n'achète pas mais
ça m'a vraiment fatigué revenant sur
tout ça en le prenant du bon côté en en
rigolant puisque toute façon maintenant
voilà en train de faire ce qu'il faut et
au moment où je fais cette vidéo je
pense que tout le monde a pris
conscience un peu de ba de l'impact
chaque action individuelle à sur le
collectif
alors attention je suis pas médecin j'ai
juste une position un peu cool pour
sensibiliser à ça en fait que je vais
utiliser clairement en tant que héros de
la nation
excusez moi le confinement ça me but au
moment je suis dans cette vidéo on né le
16 mars et avant le discours de macron
qui dit qu on est confiné se trouve
voyez cette vidéo un peu plus tard que
le prévu et du coup les choses ont
évolué il ya peut-être pas mal de trucs
que je dis qu'ils sont obsolètes
à part le fait que lui nous a dit que ça
se sera jamais obsolète bref revenons
sur tout ça tout d'abord le virus est
arrivé en france au calme limitons les
amis du fromage et du vin sur un plateau
quoi vraiment ça m'énerve les médias
part du virus pendant des semaines avant
qu'il arrive en france très tôt on était
averti que bon c'est est restreint à la
chine mais on savait très bien que tôt
ou tard voilà quand il ya une épidémie
bas ça va nous arriver pleine tête et on
va pas passer à travers les mailles du
filet à manquons ferme d'un coup toutes
nos frontières et que plus personne
n'entre essor du territoire ce qui est
impossible première l'étonnement déjà
c'est qu'on a fait même l' inverse de ça
c'est à dire qu'il ya des gens qui
reviennent de chine dont certains
carrément de buran donc moi je le dis
ouah à l'epo on va l'aider enfermé
pendant deux semaines ils pourront pas
sortir et vont devoir faire des cluedo
ils vont se faire chier à mort les
pauvres ça se trouve ils ont même pas
internet pas du tout où leur a remis un
fascicule est ce que c'est bon on trouve
ça fou parce que il ya cinq ans moi j'ai
découvert que dans des aéroports il y
avait des caméras thermiques qui servent
tout simplement à voir si des gens de la
fièvre et a potentiellement les mettre
de côté faire une batterie d'examens et
si c'est pas un nouveau virus qui se
répand très très vite et qui fait des
morts à cacouna virus
ok on place venir tels bienvenue frérot
depuis que j'ai vu ça c'était à 5 ans je
crois alors mon premier voyage au japon
je me suis dit [ __ ] mais pourquoi on
n'a pas ça en france c'est quand même un
truc 2
fondé quand même une nation c'est un
pays hyper développé on est un pays
riche c'est dingue qu'on est passé à nos
frontières alors qu'on est un pays
touristique de ouf
joseph évident que va y avoir des gens
qui vont revenir de chine ou des chinois
directement qui partent en vacances puis
là ce moment l'un qu'ils soient affectés
qu'ils savent pas vrai vous connaissez
la suite
et nous fait rien ou fait rien du cours
en très peu de temps le virus se répand
évidemment tu peux porter le virus avoir
aucun symptôme tu peux porter le virus
est juste avoir des symptômes comme une
grippe donc genre pas ouf voix et
surtout avant même les symptômes tata
petite période d'incubation la de cinq
jours après je crois pour le connais
virus pendant laquelle tu transmets des
russes aux autres bref tout ça on en
parlera thaler mais voilà le virus
commence à se répandre mais en fait il
aurait fallu déjà à ce moment-là agir
attention j'ai pas que le gouvernement
n'a rien fait du tout et c'est ça qui
s'est passé non je dis juste - le
ressenti que j'ai eu devant ça un mois
de médias qui parlent du virus et qui
disent oh la la maintenant il est en
corée au puits au japon tire du web il
vient d'arriver en italie est vraiment à
côté le gouvernement qui se dit je crois
juste qu'une bonne partie de la
population aurait aimé voir le
gouvernement 10 rebonds on a vu ce qui
se passe en italie
on sait que ça va nous arriver dans la
gueule on met dès maintenant des mesures
drastiques en place pour éviter le pire
plus tu prend des mesures en place tôt
et mieux c'est et là franchement je
trouve vraiment qu'on les a pas du tout
pris à temps genre vraiment bref après
c'est mon avis c'est mon avis mais
j'étais vraiment votre bois heureusement
depuis à des mesures qui ont été mises
en place bien énervé et tant mieux en
vrai tu vas chez qu on en souffre tous
mais tant mieux on en revient donc au
second discours d' emmanuel macron tout
ce qu'ils peuvent passer en télétravail
vous passez en télétravail je demande
aux entreprises de permettre à leurs
employés de travailler à distance les
restaurants les bars les boîtes de nuit
ce soir minuit
cette charte la fermeture à compter de
ce soir minuit de tous les lieux
recevant du public non indispensables à
la vie du pays
waouh [ __ ] ça veut dire ce que ça veut
dire là ça réagit fort ça commence à
mettre des mesures en place c'est cool
mais aller voter quand même rien ne
s'oppose à ce que les français même les
plus vulnérables se rendent aux urnes
ouais attend voter ces genres des gens
dans une file d'attenté qui se
regroupent au même endroit c'est pas à
le voter quand même il faut voter c'est
important
bon là je suis désolé j'ai pas compris
ce move genre vraiment on peut les
décalés ça va sauver des gens tu vois
pourquoi maintenir ça c'est évident
qu'il ya des gens qui ont choppé le
corona parce qu'ils sont allés voter ça
va très très vite à se transmettre sévir
à la mort la paroisse il a lancé un
festival de vidéo incroyable merci ma
crainte est le meilleur youtuber ça je
te le dire mec le samedi qui a suivi et
même le vendredi c'était déjà le cas en
vrai mais c'est fou les gens sont
devenus fous en fait c'était hyper
intéressant sociologiquement mais on
voit la peur d'un coup qui s'instaure et
les gens qui deviennent des
survivalistes en fait qui se disent il
faut vite que je prenne les choses en
main sinon je vais y passer et qui du
coup font le pire truc à savoir se
regrouper en masse dans des endroits là
quand même ya quand même eu un truc fou
font parler un bon les gens qui font des
stocks de bouffer tout aller mais je
comprends ils ont peur mais c'est quand
même le pire réflexe c'est à dire plein
de gens qui s'attroupent en même temps
au même moment au même endroit qui a
compris pourquoi les gens ont acheté en
masse du pq et ja j'ai toujours pas
combien je suis désolé j'ai pas débattu
sur ça avec mes potes si le moment j'ai
envie de débattre avec vous qui a
compris imaginez dans le pire des cas tu
va aux toilettes une a plus de papier
toilette les couilles tu as une douche
ventadoux petite étoile hausse et de
chats et devinez quoi ça nettoie mieux
c'est fou mais on a un blème avec le pq
le français gêné j'ai découvert que les
français ont un problème avec le papier
toilette j'ai vraiment découvert chez
passer des restes du lycée et du collège
au genre tu allais faire caca et il y
avait plus de paix tutu s'en apercevait
trop tard et du coup tu étais trop ma
vie parce que tu avais plus de paix qu à
ce moment là je sais pas d'où ça vient
mais bien trop mal et français en fait
de base y avait une responsabilité
individuelle qui était très faible genre
personne ne s'est dit attendre mais moi
je peux changer les choses en me
comportant mois d'une certaine manière
des gens se sont mis dans l'idée le
virus allait se répandre et que ça ne
dépendait pas du tout de leur
comportement et c'était terrible à voir
tous ces gens qui sont rués dans les
supermarchés pour faire des stocks de
malades alors pas mal de gens avaient
probablement déjà de quoi vivre une
semaine chez eux après voilà les gens
avaient peur peur aussi de manquer de
vivres depuis pouvoir manger et se
torcher le cul apparemment cambrai ça se
comprend malgré tout ça se comprend que
les gens aient paniqué se soient rués
dans les supermarchés etc
alors qu'en vrai les gens pouvaient
continuer à faire leurs courses au même
rythme que d'habitude les supermarchés
continuer d'être approvisionné donc
avait pas de souci et alors et le truc
ultime il est minuit rue de la soif à
rennes et de nombreux bars sont encore
ouverts
tout ça ça rend fou en bourse à moi ça
m'a rendu dingue
là je me tue les gens qui ont voulu
faire la fête avant la fermeture des
restaurants et des bars il faisait quoi
je suis désolé les gens se sont
regroupés pour profiter de la dernière
soirée avant la fermeture des bars et
des restaurants là là ça nous a fait
vraiment mal on n'a pas à contrer si
emmanuel macron dit que ça va fermer
c'est parce qu'il faut déjà plus y aller
au moment où il dit ça et qui rendra le
fait de ne plus y aller obligatoire à
partir d'un certain jour et d'une
certaine heure pour partir du principe
que vous êtes porteur que vous l'avez
même si vous ressentez rien où vous
n'avez pas de symptômes fait comme si
vous l'avez comme ça vous protéger les
autres ce truc là aujourd'hui j'ose
espérer que tout le monde l'a compris
mais à l'époque ya une partie énorme de
la population qu'ils avaient compris
qu'ils étaient face à une autre partie
assez énorme aussi de la population qui
avaient pas compris ça et qui faisait
tout ce qu'il fallait pas mais bon voilà
les gens voulaient boire des bières une
dernière fois dans cette dernière fois
cela profite t de la vie une dernière
fois avant le dimanche avant le jour où
ça y est on bascule dans le on arrête
les conneries on fait tous attention si
beau ce qui se passe mais il fait beau
les gens ils se baladent ils vont au
parent qui vont sur les quais y qui fit
croque la vie à pleines dents et le
corner avec en fait c'est assez
intéressant c'est juste qu'il ya une
bonne partie des gens qui ont besoin
qu'on leur impose des choses et qu'on
leur impose des règles pour agir en fait
et ils ne comprennent pas pourquoi ces
règles sont mises en place
ils agissent par obligation et papa
juste bienveillance et responsabilité
individuelle prend là là moi aussi
j'avais envie d'aller au parc inde et au
soleil de sortir avec natsu et tout mais
je n'ai pas fait je restais chez moi à
jouer warzone agréable tout ça nous
amène à lundi le jour où je tourne cette
vidéo j'ai pas encore vu discours mais
logiquement mâcon va annoncer un
confinement total c'est une bonne et une
mauvaise nouvelle une mauvaise pourquoi
pas parce que ça va nous priver un peu
de liberté c'est fini d'aller boire une
bière avec un pote d'aller au cinéma
mais d'un autre côté c'est génial parce
que c'est la meilleure chose à faire
face à ce [ __ ] de coronavirus c'est
d'ailleurs ce qu'ils ont déjà fait dans
plein d'autres pays en espagne en italie
bat en chine il ya plein de trucs qui
sont au juste pour beaucoup de gens mais
que beaucoup de gens ne savent pas en
fait tous savent en partie j'ai donc
rappelé un peu ce que c'est le
confinement
parce que voilà je suis influencé ouais
je veux des photos de mabhouh fois sur
un star le but c'est tout simplement
d'empêcher la propagation du virus en
empêchant le plus possible les
interactions entre les gens de manière à
ce que ce qui est le virus le gardent
pour eux et évite d'infecter les autres
et que le nombre de malades
arrête de monter en flèche le but c'est
d'aplatir cette fameuse courbe pour que
ça reste gérable pour les hôpitaux et le
corps médical qui croyait mois hanche
littéralement en ce moment il manque de
matériel il manque d'effectifs ils
bossent sans arrêt bref c'est vraiment
envoyer de la force la force de la fin
sur les réseaux à tous ces gens parce
que nous on se plaint d'être confiné
chez nous mais eux ils sont pas confinés
chez eux ils sont à l'hôpital accueillir
des gens tous les jours à devoir les
aider
bref le confinement est nécessaire
vraiment gardant positif en tête en plus
on a une ère où il ya internet via
netflix bref c'est l'ère où tu peux
grave te divertir de chez toi sans avoir
à bouger donc c'est quand même cool
sympa cool d'être confiné un mec cool
d'avoir accès à tout ça on a de la
chance [ __ ] monga ya 25 ans quand tu
devais te faire chier on a les activités
manuelles aussi c'est le moment si vous
voulez vous mettre une activité manuelle
vous met au dessin aller mater des tuto
sur le net
occupez-vous tout le monde a des stylos
chez soi tout le monde peut faire ça et
s'il vous plaît vraiment prenez au
sérieux les instructions du gouvernement
et de l'om est c'est hyper important
vous l'avez peut-être tous vu la fiche
là sur comment se laver les mains les
étapes etc
lavez vous les mains le plus possible
c'est vraiment pas des conneries quitte
à ce que vaut votre peau soit ça je veux
votre peau d'ailleurs soit sèche sèche
éviter tout contact avec vos proches
avec vos parents avec vos grands-parents
fait des visio tout simplement en prenez
leona sky qu'aujourd'hui on à facetime
c'est quand même cool
à une époque on envoyait des lettres
bordel je veux pas la morale du tour je
vous dis juste qu'il faut vraiment
comprendre que vous avez une vraie
responsabilité dans ce bordel vous
l'accordé cette vidéo ça n'arrive pas
qu'aux autres ça peut vous tomber dessus
moi j'ai des potes de potes là qu'ils
ont chopé dans certains qui sont dans
des états vraiment pas beau à voir c'est
pas des conneries
s'il vous plaît ne soyez pas complice de
ça fait ce qu'il faut donc voilà prenez
bien ça en compte c'est hyper importante
c'est pour une durée déterminée c'est
pas la fin du monde je rappelle aussi
que le taux de mortalité varie en
fonction de l'âge ça veut pas dire que
vous pouvez pas être vraiment normal à
cause du virus voir mourir mais ça veut
dire que d'autres gens sont encore plus
à risque et donc les plus purs d'entre
vous si vous voulez venir en aide à ces
gens là par exemple si vous avez un
voisin qui est très âgé y a pas la force
d'aller faire ses courses parce qu'il
faut acheter beaucoup d'un coup bas
proposés vous aider le aller faire les
courses à sa place et ramener les devant
sa porte vous pouvez aussi aider des
gens faisant du baby sitting bref ya
beaucoup de manières de s'entraider
c'est le moment d'être solidaire en fait
est d'aider les autres c'est maintenant
tout temps évidemment maintenant les
distances à entre nous pour pas qu'on se
contaminent évidemment il ya un site qui
a été créée du coup pour faire face
aussi à l'épidémie et qui est génial qui
s'appelle en première ligne point fr si
on a qui veulent tuer le temps d'aider
les hôtes en même temps ben voilà c'est
fait pour vous c'est un site où vous
pouvez tout simplement venir en aide à
des gens qui en ont besoin pendant
l'épidémie
vous savez que souvent les humains quand
on est vraiment dans la merde basse et
là on devient très solidaire et bien
j'aimerais le constater tout simplement
pendant cette épidémie de covile 19
voilà on va voir comment ça évolue
en tout cas moi je vais je vais beaucoup
la ix20 à huy ha oui oui j'avoue je
prends un peu à coeur les
responsabilités qu'on a
les gens qui créent du contenu là sur
internet sur tweets sur un stage sur
youtube j'ai envie qu'on vous régale
après on a moins de moyens que
d'habitude on peut pas se rassembler on
peut pas faire de tournage avec la prod
et tout mais je vais essayer proposer
plein de petits contenu je vais essayer
de faire un petit peu plus de vidéos que
d'habitude mais voilà j'espère que vous
allez bien portez vous bien en tout cas
je vous souhaite le meilleur tous les
petits gestes là que conseiller d'y
appliquer les c'est hyper-important
rendez moi fier de cette communauté
les choses iront mieux avec le temps
j'en suis sûr mais pour le moment faut
vraiment qu'on soit tous responsables et
qu'on se comporte bien j'ai dit tout ce
que j'avais à dire on verra comment ça
évolue tenez vous informés sur les
réseaux attention au fait que news à oui
j'ai pas dit ça
faites gaffe ou fake nous vraiment
informez vous sur des sources
officielles ya des comptes twitter là
qui disent des conneries total et condé
des milliers de rt faut arrêter de
répondre ces merdes pied vous vraiment
un truc officiel paniquez pas ça va
aller chez que c'est dur je t'ai pas que
ça et tu partes plaisir mais je dis que
ce pourrait être pire
allez courage à tout le monde on se
retrouve bientôt dans des lacs dans des
vidéos ça m'a fait très plaisir de
parler de ça voilà on va tourner
maintenant c'est la même pièce que là où
je rêvais live mais je vais tourner sur
fond vert comme ça on peut s'amuser avec
les images et séparer saab et viol avec
le décor mais ça fait bizarre je
retourne chez moi comme à l'ancienne a
très vite tout le monde merci d'avoir
regardé portez vous bien faites
attention à vous et surtout à vos
proches
bisous tout le monde ciao
il
[Musique]